à l'époque je ris personne aimée pas
très très peu oui moi je sais que ma
fille par exemple qui a 13 ans et ya
aussi des dizaines de milliers de
followers qui énormément suivi équipe et
déposent comme ça et moi aussi j'ai su
sa maman donc au début ressèment ça me
gênait etc
mais j'ai compris parce que la pauvre
elle s'en prend plein la gueule se fait
insulter de tous
j'ai compris qu'en fait un stage là
maintenant on ne peut rien faire il faut
juste les accompagner faut pas les
interdire pendant vous ai dit que
j'allais vous indiquez votre vie et des
lions fumée bout des pattes on ne peut
rien faire on bien sûr c'est aux parents
de faire moi je viens je vais terminer
si tu me laisses terminé j'ai dit
j'accompagne mon enfant je préfère que
ma fille me donne c'est comme instagram
que je vois qui elle parle oui je
surveille ce qui se passe plutôt
qu'elles le fassent dans mon gars tu
auras qui sont passés sur une réalité et
c'est pas bien de se voiler la face jvc
la fumée les gens danger il faut pas
failli à face dans l'école dans les
écoles ils sont tous sur les wii et sur
les pavés les noms de pêche il le faut
et je vais vous dire une règle
excuse-moi part je m'en excuse moi
pardon donc ne s'est pas intervenu en
battant c'est pas interdit les réseaux
sociaux d'instagram ils ont le droit
mais je crois que c'est à partir de 13
ans où ça doit être mis géré par un
adulte et moi bas et c'est ce que je
fais et s'estime fait je fais très bien
mon rôle de maman gilles non bravo gêné
et énervé ceci dit j'ai vécu un truc à
la maison je fais moi c'est que on avait
effectivement pris les codes un stade à
ma petite dernière qui a immédiatement
ont recréé un autre colombien s'est
découvert après des mois qu'elle avait
un autre contre 8 examens alors été
dépotoir bénin c'est ça le danger
dialogue et l'avantagent sur instagram
c'est que c'est visible et que justement
vous pouvez le voir vous l'avez vu
qu'elle est au vert en deuxième il faut
mélanger avec les enfants un groupe pas
les frustrés il faut pas les bloquer du
coup je suis désolé je prends un exemple
concret il ya alexandra rose qui est
allée jean marc en lice sur ces news
tous les matins qui a une trentaine
d'années qui est une chaîne d'info tous
les jours sur instagram un messagerie
privée elle reçoit des photos de sexes
de mecs et chaplin ça veut dire excuse
mais est ce que tu trouves normal
mais de 15 ans a cédé confié que ce
genre de chose mais vous devez entendre
on le sait mais je laisse en a parlé
ensemble sur les réseaux traîne d'été
deyris et grand corps bien bien si
effectivement il faut qu'on soit
vigilant
les excuser moi les réseaux sociaux sont
responsables oui par qui doivent
contrôler les pervers et ils doivent les
musiques amplifiées mais par contre je
trouve ça une logique de punir les
enfants de vivre de grandir et d'évoluer
ce n'est pas une posture
non mais je suis d'accord avec kevin les
enfants n'ont pas la maturité pour pour
affronter cela vous aurait dit des jeans
vieillis j'ai une fille qui va avoir 13
ans cd je peux te dire qu'aujourd'hui et
c'est difficile et je rejoins magali
aujourd'hui de 13 ans elle est mature
mais bien c'est à dire mais quand on a
des enfants tu verras à interdire les
enfants pour contrer moi je vais dire
quelque chose
j'ai fait ce café magali cirque on a les
codes et de la femme le gère très bien
on a appris en début de semaine
qu'apparemment il se harcelé à l'école
parce qu'on a eu les codes avec mon nom
et qu'on a lu un petit peu tout on a pu
parler avec elle lors de rendez vous
allez connaître cet article mais je
pense qu'au lieu d'interdire les oui
mais la raison il faudrait au panier ni
les jeunes et leur parler